so ii talk in the afternoon is going to
be given by a lingual is from microsoft
research and is interested in few early
computer science problems and also
algorithm problem arriving from practice
discussing to tell us about volatile
learning problem okay thank you for the
introduction and thanks to the
organizers for giving me a chance to
speak here thanks for coming so this is
going to be a theoretical top and this
base and joint work with lewis
Rademacher i've taken the title of this
workshop literally and i'm going to
focus on on the computational challenge
i'm not going to tell you about any new
results this will be a survey like chalk
so i'll tell you about this problem and
its connection to various other problems
when straight problems and some
approaches partial results so let me
start with a more general problem
problems learning convex bodies recently
stated there is an unknown convex body k
in a d-dimensional euclidean space it's
full dimensional so it's not restricted
to any subspace and what we get is input
z reform the random samples x1 x2 from k
and the problem is to reconstruct k so
let me make this more precise what i
mean by this
so our output is a set k prime that is
close to k in the following sense so u
sub K is the uniform probability density
on K and u sub K prime is the uniform
probability density on K Prime and they
are close enough one distance very
natural ocean and we allow improper
learning so K prime is given by a poly D
time or echo so given any point X the
Oracle tells you in quality time whether
X is in K prime or not so it could be a
neural net or polynomial threshold
function on energy ok
so there's the problem we are interested
in minimizing the number of samples that
are needed statistical complexity and
how much time is needed so let me remind
you that Peck learning of convex bodies
is hard because the VC dimensions of VC
dimension of convex bodies is unbounded
but what we are doing is we are fixing
the distribution which is uniform on the
body so so it is actually solvable and
what interested in whether how many
samples are needed how much time is
needed and this can be thought of as as
an instance of the density estimation
problem so we are only given positive
samples unlike in fact learning where we
get positive negative samples but we
have this restriction on the density
lights are convex it's a uniform
distribution convex body ok so what can
we say about this in constant dimensions
you can solve this problem by just like
in the plane you can just fit a
piecewise linear curve convex star and
that does the job and similarly in high
dimensions we can again fit a piecewise
linear surfaces but its complexity seems
to scale exponentially with D so that's
not very useful
so interiorly one feels that in high
dimensions is too much room and the
problem is inherently hard in the sense
that if you have the cube and it's too
low the end corners and you really have
to go there and check if the corner is
there or not
otherwise you don't know it's there so
you cannot really solve the problem but
let me remind you of the the result of
Daiya fisken and it shows that
interesting things can happen in higher
dimensions if you have randomized
algorithms so volume computation of
convex bodies can be done in polynomial
time but they assume a stronger access
to the body which is the membership
Oracle not just random points and so
membership Oracle is is that for any
given X the algorithm can ask the Oracle
whether the x point ax is in key or not
and they give a polynomial time
algorithm for solving this problem and
all
so for generating random point so this
is a stronger axis so we could ask if
our problem is hard if we give stronger
access to the algorithm by providing it
the membership irako so you want to
learn convex bodies under membership
Oracle's and random points polynomial
time polynomial complexity or sample
complexity so isn't the what can't you
just output the Oracle at the answer
what does it mean to learn oh yeah so we
we can okay I guess you can't do that we
want to have our own set which you you
can make polynomial number of queries
and then you you have to answer all the
next new query exactly that's not me
right
okay so it is actually hard the
intuition I give a real sort of makes
sense and the result is that you need to
do the square root of B over epsilon
samples so this is sample complexity
lower bound to learn to learn complex
bodies and this was done in two
different papers so how do you prove
such a result so essentially what you
have to do is you have to construct a
large family of convex bodies large is
very large W exponential in D which have
these two conflicting properties so any
two bodies in the family are far from
each other in the l1 distance sense but
if you just make polynomial number of
queries either membership or random
points then after you make polynomial
number of queries to a body there will
be still many other bodies in this
family which look right which will be
consistent with the parries that you
made so polynomial number of queries are
not sufficient to tell apart your body
from other bodies in this family so the
construction of this family in the
second paper is very simple I'll tell
you right here it's just intersection of
random hospices turns into a sphere
right so you take a sphere and you not
going to tell you the parameters here
this and you just row random uniformly
random half-spaces exponential in D or
square would be and that gives you one
one convex body and you do this
experiment many times and that gives you
the family and with some constant
probability is going to satisfy those
those current conditions
I'm going to mention that so their
problem is about when you put the
uniform distribution on the ambient
space not uniform sorry Gaussian and
then you do Peck learning so you get
positive and negative samples and you
want to learn the body so that's not
clear I will say because in our case
about the distribution adapts itself to
the body that can be useful its uniform
on the body and that can provide useful
information some sometimes I'll show you
some results where we can solve the
problem but can't be solved in this
model we don't know how to solve it in
this model so they did I don't know
exact what exactly was the relation
between the two models okay so that's
there's the construction but a little
hard to provide intuition for this so
I'll tell you the construction from the
other paper which is also quite simple
and maybe little easier to provide
intuition for okay so we'll start with
the the cross polytope in our Nardi this
is just a convex hull of the plus minus
one standard unit vectors or the l1 ball
this to do the d facets to Roberta C's
and now we can attach a pyramid or fixed
height to the facets of this right so
this parameter here here anywhere same
height and I choose the height so that
if I attach all the pyramids the body is
still convex so I find the maximum
height so that still remains convex and
now my heart family is going to be the
convex bodies you get by attaching
pyramids to any subset right two to
three to two Z 2 to B 2 to the D subsets
and each of them gives you a convex body
now to to learn the convex body you
basically want to find which of the
parameters are there or not
and you have to go and check for them
otherwise you don't know so you have to
make Spinelli many queries so polynomial
number of careers are insufficient to
determine which body you got after so
but this is not quite work because the
total number of total volume of all
these pyramids can be at most one over D
fraction of the volume of the cross
polygon so if you just output the cross
polytop as your answer that would be a
good answer for this family so this this
family doesn't quite work but there is
an easy fix for this which is hardness
amplification using
Moulton sir product so or this Cartesian
product so we take new convex bodies in
part of the square root D and we take
these cross poly talks with pyramids and
take the Cartesian products of these
quarries so this gives us a new family
and satisfies for the conditions that we
had before okay so the learning convex
body is hard oh I need to I should tell
you about this so then Louis asked the
question whether the volume can be
estimated from polynomially many random
samples and that's you can't actually do
that exponentially many samples needed
to do that so
so that second knife no is it like fully
exponential well that's not the point it
was not no maybe you're thinking of
deterministic algorithms that was known
for long time I see forever
there's no Oracle only holy samples
so all these convex bodies have very
complex boundaries exponential number of
facets and that's what seems to make
them hard to learn so it would be
interesting to restrict our family of
convex bodies so one of the canonical
class projects body it is poly to offset
and facets or basically intersection of
em half-spaces this small VC dimension
and polynomial m and D so we can do PAC
learning in terms of sample complexity
poly MD samples but computationally we
don't know how to do is we don't even
know how to do it for two half spaces
and there are many cryptographic
hardness results there are algorithms
for learning intersection of
intersections of m half spaces under
fixed distributions law concave
distribution is Gaussian distributions
so for Gaussian the best result so far
is the minimum of T to the log M over
epsilon square and M over epsilon to the
M so it's not polynomial and DNN that we
don't know how to do that but there are
in general there are computational
hardness results for for many
oscillators here yeah I'm not sure if
there are there is one for that okay so
for Gaussian there are pretty good
algorithms but they are not polynomials
yet in dnm and our problem is uniform on
the polytope so we only get positive
examples and we have to put this extra
condition which is not very important
really is that the intersection is
bounded in the case of intersection
hospices there is no boundedness
condition and it also means that our
number of facets has to be at least D
plus one
okay because she omits em to the log n
times
oh okay answer yeah that's you after
your yeah
so let me restate the polytope learning
problem we have a polytope unknown
positive P that most M facets we get
Polly number random samples and we want
to efficiently reconstruct P so let me
just mention one more aside what if we
allow ourselves membership or Akal in
this case and then this problem was
steady long time ago and the you can
Packer in polynomial time result of
cracking bit 97 okay but we are
interested in that problem okay so let
me tell you where we are in the talk I
told you about learning convex bodies
polytop learning problem and now I'm
going to talk about some approaches and
partial results the first approach so
far I haven't actually said why the
sample complexity of this problem is
polynomial all right so it's it does not
immediately follow from back learning
results even though the VC dimension of
these this class is small but that does
not immediately imply that the better
the polytop learning can be solved in
polynomial number of samples but it
follows quite easily from VC results so
the way to solve this problem the sample
complexity problem is you take the
minimum volume polytop queue that
contains all the samples and has at most
M facets
why is that a good reconstruction why is
that a good solution so first we observe
that if P 1 P 2 R 2 polytopes is that
most and facets then v c-dimension of
the class which is the difference
between two polytopes is also the same d
M log M now for the minimum volume
polytop Q it's L it's total variation
distance from P is can be rewritten as
the volume of P minus Q over the volume
of P and this requires a little bit of
computation but uses the fact that the
volume of Q is at most volume of P and
then we just use the VC theorem VC
uniform convergence theorem to say that
these two things are approximated by the
sample point they are proportional to
the sample points not in Q and number of
sample points total number of sample
points and we know that this number is 0
by our construction of Q so so this
number is small so Q is a good
approximation but how can we find this
polytop it turns out that even finding
the smallest volume and closing simplex
is np-hard
but that's not a hurdle for us because
our data is not worst case it comes from
a structured distribution so we can try
to find various heuristics to to use
that structure but we have not succeeded
and we don't even know how to learn the
class of cubes using this approach but
the cubes can be learned using a
different approach which is which I tell
you about now this is the method of
moments
it's a general method for estimating the
parameters of probability distributions
estimate the moments meaning
variance-covariance and other statistics
of the sample and then you try to find
the parameters that produce those
estimated moments this was first used by
Pearson to learn mixtures of gaussians
so how do we apply this method for our
problem so it follows more more
generally parallel pipettes can also be
learned so let me be a little more
precise about what I mean by learning
these things so here we are given
samples from a parallelepiped which is X
equal to a s plus B X and s are random
variables in Rd B is vector and a is a
non singular matrix and s is uniformly
random in the cube so basically you are
taking the cube we are applying a linear
and affine transform and we get to see
the samples of X and we want to
reconstruct the parallelepiped in this
case we'll do proper reconstruction now
they are welcome back to that so we'll
do proper reconstruction by estimating a
and B so here in this picture I am just
saying that there is some parallel pipe
it somewhere and we get random samples
that we only get to see the samples you
want to find very they came from and
this problem reduces to learning cubes
the hard part is learning cubes where so
we can assume that a is the rotation
matrix and B is 0 so I'll focus on this
problem from here oh there is an easy
reduction from pella by vista cubes ok
so so this was shown in two different
communities
please jerem color in computer science
and and in in signal processing it was
more or less well-known for a long time
so the algorithm they gave is very
simple so we
define the fourth directional moment of
the cube in Direction V and for now let
me assume that the cube is axis parallel
for the moment let me assume that so in
Direction B the fourth moment is the
expectation of V dot X D for X is a
random sample from the cube and then the
cube is X is aligned there is a very
simple formula for this it is a constant
minus another constant times the sum of
the force powers of the compose the
coordinates of V so we can draw this
here this is a polar plot for the
function f of B in Direction B this
distance is the value of F of V right
you can see in this picture that the
local minima as V varies over this
sphere the unit sphere the local minima
F of V are exactly these four points
they correspond to the facets of the Q
right so if the if your cube was not
axis aligned in general position then
the fourth moment would also rotate in
accordingly and by finding the local
minima we would be able to find the
facets and so we will be able to find
the matrix a and that will solve the
problem and we can estimate these
directional samples from polynomial
number of moments and local minima can
be found efficiently by projected
gradient descent so this solves the cube
learning problem so freeze Jairam Kernan
asked about learning polytop so this is
probably the first instance there I know
this to be the first place where the
problem was asked and particularly they
asked about learning syntheses
so we showed that synthesis can be
learned efficiently
let me contrast this result with the
problem of learning PAC learning when
the distribution is Gaussian
distribution so they're the best
algorithm requires time D to the log D
for our set up we can do it in
polynomial time so there is some
difference between the two problems
there are results for training neural
networks particularly this result which
works for one here and there but does
not seem to be applicable to our problem
because the top get there is a some gate
and and I don't know how to make it work
for our problem so let me say a little
bit about proof we give two proofs the
first proof is just basically the same
thing as what we saw for the cube we use
the third directional moment but the
problem the reason f JK didn't do it was
probably that the computation of the
polynomials becomes harder even though
it's lower degree but more Elise uses
the same general ideas the other proof
is the reduction from independent
component analysis reduction to
independent component analysis and we
can also do other bodies like LP balls
or in particular the cross poly tope so
let me quickly say what independent
component analysis is it's a very well
studied technique in signal processing
and also many other areas it's so we
have this model X is a random variable
given by a times s is a long singular
matrix and s is a random variable what
we know about it is that components s 1
s 2 s D are independent they are not
Gaussian but we don't know their
distribution
we also don't know the metric say we are
given samples of X and we want to
estimate a efficiently so that's the I
see a problem our problem learning cubes
is a special case of this then s is
uniform from minus 1 1 to the D so the
results of freeze erm : and the other
papers actually apply to I see so they
solve a more general problem so let me
just very quickly say how we reduce
learning simply sees - I see a so
standard D minus 1 dimensional simplex
in Rd so the demands 1 dimensional
simplex but we embed it in Rd just the
usual thing Sigma of X I is 1 and all
the variables are non-negative then if
you have a uniform the random sample
from the simplex X and R is a scalar
random variable with density
proportional to X to the B minus 1
Thanks e to the negative X then our X
has independent non-negative components
so it basically the problem becomes
independent component analysis problem
after you do this multiplication by this
random scalar so that's all I'll say
about this reduction
our standard
so tensor decomposition methods are
another way to utilize the moment
information not very different from
polynomial optimization technique that
we just saw
they have been recently very popular for
latent variable models when you skip
this part I was just explaining here an
example of how tensor decomposition is
used for solving ICA it is but here I
want to just point out that learning
simply sees turns out to be a special
case of latent directly a location which
we saw in the first stop of the workshop
and Lda was shown to be vulnerable using
tensor decomposition around the same
time by uncommon foster shukracharya in
view so this is another connection of
polytop learning to a fairly well stated
problem we didn't know about these
things and quite surprised to learn
about these connections the intensity
composition has been used for many other
problems recently hidden Markov models
mixture of gaussians okay but our main
interest is in whether we can use the
method of moments to learn pointers more
general polytopes
right so so far what I show you is that
we can learn cubes simply sees closed
polytopes all of them share the property
that they are highly symmetric and in
some sense these are the only symmetric
polytopes in high dimensions but then we
go to modal bolotoff the symmetry is
lost so if we if we change this if I
deform the cube in some way then my
my fourth moment will deform so it if I
change this thing here then it's going
to make changes over here as well now
I'll not be able to find the facet as
local minima of this side so making
changes over here changes the force
moment curve everywhere and that seems
to make it very hard to use the moment
method for general polytopes the
formulas just become very complex so we
don't know how to do that but let me
mention this result which is exactly
construction of polytopes now this is
for n vertices not M facets but this
class also has small VC dimension so
it's learn at all and this can be done
with first MD moments in D plus one
random directions so this uses a formula
that relates the directional moments to
the vertices and uses a different way it
does not use optimization of polynomials
or tensor decomposition so the system
polynomial equations but doesn't help
with the our problem because it uses
very high degree moments and to compute
KS directional moment degree K moment
since that we need at least to do the
Omega K samples so this result is not
helpful for our problem
the question is if you can learn
polytopes the directional moments of
constant order we don't want to use
moments of such a high order and these
moments can be computed in polynomial
time from our samples
make that question precise and for that
let me state this simple definition the
third directional moment in Direction B
is just this expectation of V dot X
cubed and we can take the expectation
inside and these terms define the third
moment tensor so this is d by D by D
array D ijk is equal to this expectation
of X I XJ XK D cube numbers and they can
all be estimated velvet polity samples
and once we have these D cubed numbers
we can estimate this for any be right by
plugging in the values here this works
for all K it's similar
it's directional moment can be estimated
from case moment tensor so here is a
more precise version of the question the
method of moment can so positive
learning so I just put some fixed
numbers here they are not very important
as does the hundredths moment tensor
suffice to determine polytope with at
most 10 d facets information
theoretically so if we want to do it
algorithmically but even information
theoretical Z can we do that so more
precisely if we have two positives P and
Q Rd and the 100th moment tensors are
the same does that imply the two volley
dots are the same and the answer is
unfortunately no so we can construct
polytopes
there are different even though their
moments first 100 moment tensors are the
same and the construction is quite
simple so I'll give you the construction
so the basically it comes down to
degeneracy if we go to the plane and if
you look at B Gaunt's in the plane then
they can't be determined by the 100
moment tensor because if you look at a
deal on
there is a 2d dimensional object because
each point here is two coordinates so
overall it has to rida menschell object
and then we are taking it down to a
moment tensor 100 moment tensor which
has a hundred dimension so that there
are going to be polygons which are
different but then mat to the same
moment answer the tensor has size each
other so it's a to the x100 dr in r2
right now 99 and so on we are in the
plane so
there are two different polygons p1 and
p2 which have the same first hundred
moment answers and then using these two
we can we can lift these 2d dimensions
by this very simple construction the 3d
just looks like a cylinder in general we
just augment these extra coordinates
which come from the cube right and these
two polytopes have the same moments it
is very simple calculation basically
it's factorizes in the moments over p1
moments over the rest of the coordinates
these two are equal by a construction
then these are the same objects so they
have the same moments moment answers so
the first hundred moment answers can't
distinguish between polytopes so let me
just connect this thing to other models
that are studied and this degeneracy
phenomenon so degeneration is actually
quite common in other latent variable
models that are studied in mixtures of
gaussians the result of kakari and xu
which gives you efficient algorithms for
large number of gaussians requires that
that means be in general position the
means of the Gaussian be in general
position if they are not in general
position cereal on the line then the
information theoretic requirement can be
exponential in the number of gaussians
there are constructions Moitra Valiant
and there are more general constructions
which were in considerably more
generality
sorry problem related to what this thou
shalt make sure all the lower bounds
that you are mentioning these were laws
apply only for the parameter estimation
and this whole game opera married
instruction right yeah so I'm I want an
evaluator not a generator
but there is a difference here in
polytop learning from what happens in
the gaussian mixtures case in the sense
that here the simple complexity is still
small even the degenerate case that i
said because the smallest volume
polytope queue that always works
regardless of what degeneracy is there
in the body table so there is a
difference here from the other
degeneracy phenomena so can we save our
conjecture our question so one easy way
out would be to ask if moments of first
hundred moment tensor suffice to
determine these poly toss with ten D
facets
if the normals are in general position
but okay so let's I don't know the
answer to that so so this shows that we
have to be a little the motor moment
doesn't work directly like if you
compute the moments and then you want to
get the polytope back then that does not
work and we have to do more work maybe
we have to work with conditional moments
or something else that's all about the
method of moments I will tell you about
a third approach route on transform I
don't have any new results here but I
think the approach is quite interesting
so I just wanted to show you so rad on
transform is a widely used technique in
computerized tomography here I will just
show you a special case for our
situation it works more generally so if
you are in the plane and you have some
organ that you don't have direct access
to but you can send an x-ray in any
direction that you want so you can send
x-ray along this line and on the other
side you can check how much the signal
was attenuated so then you can figure
out what the distance along this line is
what the length of the intersection is
radon transform is a function that maps
these lines to the distance of the
intersection okay so radon transform of
K evaluated at line L is just the
intersection that
the question is can be recovered K given
the value of radon transform at all
lines and this answer turns out to be s
the formula for reconstructing K from
from there our own transform and this
works in higher dimensions too so but in
high dimensions I will not work with
what is probably the more natural
generalization where you take the convex
body and you take the length of
intersection to the line instead of a
line you will work with D minus 1
dimensional hyper planes so so the radon
transform now is a function from the
hyper planes to reals adjust the value
of the area of the intersection of the
hyper plane in the body ok so let me
just show you the an example of the
inversion formula what it looks like I
will not do anything with it this is in
r3 so if this is the radon transform at
HP the plane then this is the area of
the intersection then we can define this
mod is called do R around transform and
this is a function of points in the
space it is a very natural thing it's
just the at any point X you take all
planes that pass through it and take the
value of radon transform there and
integrate it then we can reconstruct the
body with this very simple formula you
once you have this do radon transform we
apply the laplacian operator that
magically gives the
indicator function of the convex body K
so can we apply this how can we apply
this to our problem and there is similar
formula in higher dimensions there is
some chance of applying it to our
problem but for that we need to know the
value of there are on transform for all
hyper planes that can be estimated
easily because that I don't transform
over the volume so this should be the
volume of the body is basically it can
be approximated so we want to know the
volume of this intersection instead of
that if we take a band around it very
thin band then the volume of this is the
area of this intersection times the
width is a good approximation of the
volume of this bag right and that volume
is approximated by the number of points
sample points at na here so we can use
that to approximately compute all of
those numbers and this holds for all
hyperplanes by the the bc by the uniform
convergence theorem for VC classes so we
can approximately compute the radon
transform for all points and then we can
invert by the inversion formula and you
can learn the convex body right but of
course that can't work the problem is
that radon transform is very sensitive
to errors it has been very well studied
for in two and three dimensions in
higher dimensions I don't know much
about how how to handle the errors and
that second hurdle is the computation of
inversion vision balls formulas
integrals over the unit sphere high
dimensional sphere and multiple
differentiations but the bit our special
case of polytope learning might be
easier
so why it's possible that this approach
will work let me also don't seem to have
the degeneracy problems with a matter of
moments did let me conclude so I talked
about polytop learning problem and B so
its relation to ICA Lda so application
of the method of moments and around
transform they can be seen as a general
type of method where we take the
polytope and we are applying some linear
transformation and then get some new
data and from that we are trying to get
back the original polytope and there can
be many other linear transformations
this is Fourier transform but I don't
think that works here but there may be
some others so maybe there are can be
designed although being a transform that
allow efficient solving of the problem
Thanks
[Applause]
so can you also reconstruct just from
lights entire dimension you can yeah
there are four with us but but we don't
know how to estimate along those and
when you take the hyperplane we can use
the BC theorem to estimate the the
intersection area but for a line I don't
know how to do that the length of the
intersection question they're similar
things not fighter plane for more
general I'll say algebraic I don't know
I don't know it's also very doublet in
mathematics your mathematics but I don't
know what they do there okay that will
have a 30 minutes away
[Applause]